[Applause]
i know it's exciting time of year it's
halloween weekend is this your favorite
my oh i love it when it falls on a
sunday halloween you know you scare the
kids with stories about evil demons and
ghosts then after church
you go
trick-or-treating
now i do
i see you got your masks dirty on uh
i do love halloween i do you know we the
one time you dress up and pretend to be
something we're not
also
also known as instagram but but this
this is a holiday
now i uh
i have i got sold to this birthday i
went to see the halloween movie sequel
have you seen that i tell you jamie lee
curtis looks fantastic at 62. she really
does but
in the movie kind of a karen
no really
she sees michael myers killing a kid and
she goes you're not from this
neighborhood
that's
certainly not seeing it the right way
but you know
you know who jamie curtis's mom is right
generally starred in the greatest horror
movie of all time psycho
psycho now look psycho's been out 61
years so i hope i'm not giving anything
away
at the end now but when anthony perkins
shows up with that knife wearing his
mother's dress and the wig it just
changed cinema forever and also dave
chappelle
now of course out here in california
pot's been legal for a while as in many
states not all stupidly but yeah okay
so obviously this time of year halloween
we're all local news is just full of
watch out for pot edibles that look like
candy
like i'm going to waste my stash on
children
children
i don't even like children
i put a sign on my lawn this year it
said no candy supply chain issues
[Applause]
oh no i mean there are supplies are you
having trouble getting [ __ ] you need
i don't have all the [ __ ] i need this
year i'm trying to get kids to put
toilet paper on my house
but
but you know where the president is he's
overseas right now he was in rome
yesterday he met with the pope
pope i got to say
pope gets along a lot better it looks
like to me with the democrats i mean
look at him with biden he looks like
he's a pretty happy camper obama loved
him
trump
i'm just
saying but uh joe
biden's a very at home let's put it that
way at vatican city because it's it's a
lot like delaware it's a made-up tiny
little state that no one pays taxes in
i
didn't have any food
we have the uh
we have the senator from delaware
let's
warm him up with that one i got it
no but there was one awkward moment at
the vatican yesterday when the pope
offered last rites on biden's spending
bill that was
because that
well that thing that the democrats still
fighting with themselves over this
spending bill is this process just will
not end it's it's like a blinking
contest between two people who've had
too much botox
and you know
and the democrats still trying to figure
out what this kirsten cinema wants i'm
not even sure she's wrong i just know
what she wants i think speak woman
she's that person in a relationship
where
she doesn't know where she wants to go
to dinner but she knows it's not where
you want to go
but
what is still in the bill that the
democrats are going to put child tax
credits up to 3 600 have you ever got
universal
pre-kindergarten uh free child care for
the poor and
subsidized child care up to 115 000 if
you make that yeah as always
nothing for us people who are smart
enough to wear the condom
nothing never anything for us
and finally this is kind of big news
facebook is changing its name and its
whole culture toward the virtual
changing the name to meta
it's gonna be all of course i read this
on facebook it may not be true
you